okay so here are five people who we
think might be able to replace Jon
Stewart first of all his two people that
won't John Oliver has his own show on
HBO which is a network without abs why
would you even consider going back to
Comedy Central to Amy Poehler she's got
so many projects on the good that
there's no way she'd moved to the
sausage factory at Comedy Central Comedy
Central should be looking for someone
fresh someone hungry probably someone
right under their nose number one
Jessica Williams she has been a daily
show correspondent since 2012 she is
killing it whip-smart very funny has the
comedy chops and is also the fan
favorite for the job number two hari
Kondabolu he is having incredible last
12 months with his comedy album waiting
for 20-40 to exploding plus he has a
master's in human rights from the London
School of Economics can you imagine
getting rejection letter I'm sorry Hari
Kondabolu you're overqualified for the
job number three Trevor Noah he is a
comedy rock star in his home of South
Africa and Noah most recently became a
contributor to The Daily Show in 2014
and let's face it he's incredibly
handsome and if there's one reason to
put someone on TV it's that they're very
handsome number four Cameron Esposito
she's a writer podcaster comedian
activist if you're under 30 you may have
seen her work on buzz feed her truth
bombs are always on point number five
Aziz Ansari if you can look past his
past in retro Sona you will see one of
the sharpest stand-ups of a generation a
lot of people have been asking me if I
are we taking on the job and let's just
say I won't from within and I won't roll
it out and that's a matter for Comedy
Central to the site
out of him